we have the story here from the New York
Post Mia M.I.A says is it Mia it's M.I.A
right M.I.A says she faced career
backlash for saying Jesus is real well
that of course explains why this country
is falling apart I'm only half kidding
actually Mia says the fact the biggest
backlash in my career and life I'm
facing after saying Jesus is real is
such a revelation to me people who
control these apps rather me be a bad
girl than a good one
that right there says it all
this is she's she's a rapper is that
what she does
um yeah r b r b and the Machine goes
after her because she says Jesus is real
I I I'm not a staunch Christian you know
religious person I do believe in God but
that says a lot to me when she says
they'd rather her be a bad girl they
want kids to have bad influences they
want degeneracy the algorithms of tick
tock versus in the United States versus
China and China's engineering and
Science in the United States it's
pronouns and gender I was talking about
I was learning about Kinsey last night
you guys know this doctor oh yeah
Sheamus the sex doctor and he is one of
his students was Hugh Hefner who later
became the Playboy guys started Playboy
and they were all about sexualizing
Society they'd go to colleges and
they're like we are going to sexualize
everybody yeah man let's do it and
that's we're still looking at it now
we're down to generacy without any shame
at all and it's a shame that today it's
more controversial for a celebrity at a
sage that Jesus is real uh then for them
to suggest that oh maybe they're are our
two genders or maybe that toddlers
shouldn't have sex changes or maybe the
world isn't systemically racist they are
targeted for having their own personal
beliefs and faith and for in her example
wanting to be a good girl not wanting to
be some only fans model who is teaching
young girls they have to shop their
bodies around for validation when all
actuality like like what truly are they
trying to criminalize here what kind of
thought are they really trying to
demotivate and and and it's sickening
because as you said it it it's the first
step towards this grooming not just in
the sense of sexualizing young children
but also trying to over sexualize just
even adults like why can't women young
women women who aren't children have
good role models and why can't they
believe that Jesus is real it's
absolutely insane is there a context for
her statement did you guys ever she's
she's recently uh become religious and
uh she's she says I believe in it I'm
not gonna lie to you she said it on
stage uh I don't know I think she
tweeted it yeah just just those three
words she said basically all my fans
might turn against me because they are
all progressives who hate people that
believe in Jesus Christ in this country
in an apple music interview even if it
cost me my career I won't lie I will
tell the truth and I will tell you
what's on my mind and my heart if I'm
coming back now saying Jesus Israel
there's a point Bravo man I think
there's a lot of atheists that are or or
just people maybe some sort of realists
that are like yo if a guy dies then he's
no longer real like he was real but now
he's gone I don't know man I I feel like
you you've got so many people who
believe in simulation Theory as well as
DMT the veil and machine elves where I'm
just like at a certain point you've got
to not like you could be agnostic but I
don't know how you be atheists and just
think that we're wet robots that cease
to exist when we die yeah because we
also have video of John Lennon and like
so is John Lennon real I mean it's a
weird argument and they're gonna have
like deep fakes of us after we're gone
they're gonna take they can take your
your social media profiles and create a
fake version of you that's creepy dude
yeah that's the singularity right there
you'll you will not exist but there will
be a weird facsimile of you existing but
my point is just like when we have
people come on the show or when people
go on Joe Rogan over and talk about DMT
and they talk about breaking through the
veil and seeing machine elves and stuff
it's like hey there's something else
beyond all this it's just I don't know
why people think that what they can
touch smell see in here is just it and
there's nothing else that's weird to me
yeah that's one dimension out of many
dimensions that we're all in that we're
all kind of and people people got to
understand man if you are just a wet
robot that is the electrical impulses in
your brain create the perception of you
that is a tiny fraction of the universe
the universe is massive electrical
impulses on a larger scale do you think
the the the the chemical Pathways and
the neurons in your brain is the most
intricate possible pattern that exists
there's something bigger than that like
let's
the the system that creates you in your
mind with the electrical impulses there
is a much larger version than that
version of that in the universe I
guarantee you you are not the end-all
be-all that's the crazy thing to me you
know what I mean how deep do you want to
go
down and it's such a symptom of the
narcissism I think that we see today
everyone just thinks things start with
them and end with them and so it's so
easy to just not want to believe in a
higher power in Jesus Christ and all
these things but for me as a Christian
it's personal because I feel like it
would be very hard to go day after day
without having faith in something bigger
than me
um and thinking that you know maybe like
there is a broader plan at play here and
so but yeah I think it really does to
your point just goes back to narcissism
that so many people have today whereas
we don't want to believe that there is
someone guiding us or something guiding
us you know I'll play this way if you
think you are just a wet robot and your
brain is a wet computer do you think the
human computer is the epitome the the
most powerful
wet computer that exists in the universe
that to me is an insane proposition that
someone could be like I think we're just
wet robots there's nothing else and it's
like okay well there's something a
hundred times more powerful than you as
a wet robot with better computational
Powers more perception and then to
assume that what we can touch smell see
in here is reality is insane to me yeah
it's like it's like hubris almost yeah I
was asking chat GPT about Pride because
I get hung up on this Catholic Pride as
a sin but American Pride is a wonderful
thing and I'm like chat GPT you know
this AI program on the internet which
you should all check out chat GPT is
fascinating
um what's what's the deal why do they
say it's a sin but we should do it and
it's like you know it is a sin but a
little is okay I'm like why is a
deadliest a little bit of a deadly sin
okay and it's like well uh some pride is
can be healthy but it is generally I'm
like uh why some you know so I went on
with this computer and I think there's a
difference between self-love and
narcissism but we need to find that
within ourselves in the age of social
media it's very easy to fall into
narcissism like I would make an internet
video I put it up I'd watch it just to
you know watch it and then I find that
I'm enjoying it I like myself so I'd
watch it a second time I I'm laughing
I'm like I want to watch it again and
then I'm like yo that's too far I'm
becoming the tracking the lights you're
tracking the followers and then your own
self-worth is devalued if it doesn't hit
the the metrics that you wanted to right
so it's just like it's such a trap like
if you truly do fall in love with
yourself to the extent that you know you
also I feel like get a little bit of
validation from other people especially
in the world that we're in as content
creators it's just like you've gotta
want you have to believe in something
more like I think for your own mental
health for your own well-being it's just
like I don't know it keeps me sane
personally but what got you to believing
that I think for me it was it's it's a
little bit of a selfishness of Peace of
Mind in a sense you know I think that
again believing in a higher power and
having the ability to have faith and and
a God and Jesus Christ uh is something
that has always been pivotal to just me
being able to say that I am not always
going to be in control and I'm okay with
that the things that are for me are for
me and the things that are not are not
uh and it's about just allowing yourself
to just kind of be at the whim of
something else for a little bit and not
just pretending as if you know
everything ends and starts with you
because I think that again it's a
narcissism that pervades our society
today but it's also something that's
incredibly prevalent within my
generation Generation Z it's like we are
the center of our universe when we're
not the center of everyone else is and I
think the sooner that you displace
yourself from that myth
um the happier you'll be because you'll
have so much less pressure on your own
shoulders when you actually just don't
believe that you are the end-all be all
to everything else
um when you have that that belief and
motivation of the power of something
outside of you how do you get motivated
personally I think for me it's that well
the belief I think is rooted in the fact
that you have to come from a place of
like where you we're at a Crossroads and
you didn't really know where you wanted
to go right like you you've tried
everything you've taken every turn
you've thought about all the options but
you just generally don't know and I
think you have to be to a place where
and the Bible talks about you have to be
humbled and you have to be brought to
your knees and you have to just seek
guidance from somewhere and I choose to
seek it from him and I think that like
that's just where I get the motivation
is that that God has a predestined
purpose for all of us and I think that
it would be
it would be a neglect of of my gifts and
my talents that he gave me to not
fulfill that by being motivated by being
you know someone who has a work ethic
right because it's just like my grandma
would say something to me oftentimes
when I was growing up is that God's your
talents are God's gift to you but what
you do with those talents is your gift
to God and I think like that's something
that like always resonated with me I
went through a phase where I was like yo
being famous being on stage being
wealthy everyone's screaming my name
while I'm playing for a crowd that's
narcissism man that's that's selfishness
I don't but what I realized was not
doing that is selfish I need to fulfill
my destiny or whatever this is goal yeah
that's it's it's ego to keep me from
doing it yeah the ego that's right you
know Ian hiding your talents and your
beautiful face from the world that's
pure narcissism everybody needs to see
more of you your ego can stop you from
becoming great and you need to keep your
ego in check that's interesting uh idea
though typically honest they say that uh
people who are who are famous tend to be
narcissists because these are the people
who feel like they need to be out there
and everyone needs to see them it's
interesting I thought you know like it
is part of their
the part of their Destiny part of their
your people who who are arrogant are
more likely to be famous because they
put themselves in these positions to
become famous and they believe they
deserve it too right they believe they
deserve the fame so they chase it more
actively exactly but I think it's
interesting is like you know we talk
about such big ideas even around this
table it takes a little bit of
narcissism to think that you have
solutions to these problems right which
is like it's it's the conundrum is that
like it you really do have to believe in
yourself to even be able to vocalize
like this is the direction we need to go
as a country this direction but again
it's it's unchecked narcissism and ego
but I don't I don't I wouldn't say
narcissism I think for some people it is
like you know if I come out and I say I
think Kevin McCarthy can't do the job I
think Ron Paul would do it better I
wouldn't call that narcissism I'm not
talking about myself I wouldn't want to
be in Congress I don't think I have the
solutions I just like to see somebody
else do it but sometimes you could do it
better and saying that is actually not
narcissistic you're just being self in a
way selfless like I don't want the role
but I could do it better so I'm gonna do
it kind of there's some there's a lot of
things that I think that of myself I'm
really good at complaining on the
internet you know a lot of people yeah
prove it everyone here at this table
really good at it but uh I'm I wouldn't
pretend to be anywhere near as good as
like statesmanship than someone like Ron
Paul yeah like that dude got elected
several times he knows how to speak to
his constituents he knew how to
represent them effectively and that's
why he was in for as long as he was he
didn't become president though that's a
different ball game yeah you know that's
not statesmanship that's I don't know
what you'd call that it's got to meet
the moment I think at the end of the day
like yeah did you vote for Ron Paul in
08 Luke you couldn't he wasn't on the oh
he didn't make them on the ballot yeah
well you could write him in
I think I I wrote in man bear pig that
year McCain hell are you crazy Mr Bama
Iran no no
Moran yeah no way yeah him and um
I mean it was like two uh narcissistic
sociopaths like McCain and Obama I I
literally put down man bear pig I had a
feeling that uh Ron Paul and 08 was
gonna be the bring balance to the force
I might have told you guys this before
it felt very much I was like oh it's
like what he's Darth Vader coming to
bring balance to the force and what that
means was he eradicated all the Jedi so
now there was none and there was a dick
too so there was right but it was after
a total annihilation of the system and
maybe Ron would have oversaw an
annihilation of this system that's
imploding right now much quicker and
more controlled and that was the balance
that I was feeling he was going to bring
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time